day 19 of the Russian invasion of
Ukraine let's see what sort of advances
have been made by the Russians and see
how well those Ukrainian defenses are
holding up lending us his military
expertise as air marshal Edward Stringer
Ed talk us through the developments of
the last 24 hours what are the key areas
we have to look at now
well I think what's being gradually
revealed here is is Russia's Plan B
if we look into the southern region this
is where Russia has been most militarily
successful in its long-standing aim to
link Russia through the Dom bass into
Crimea though you will note that
mariopol is still holding out and we've
seen those terrible scenes of the city
being bombarded that might be why
Odessa has not yet been progressed by
the Russians this is the dog that hasn't
barked and though we see the probings it
would appear that Russia can't assemble
a force to take what is an obvious prize
if we come up to the east similarly we
see probings here that would cut off
this prop pocket where you've marked up
the Ukrainian forces clearly a sensible
military thing to do but they don't the
Russians appear able to assemble a force
that could complete it and then if we
come up into the north around Kiev we
see activity on those thrusts that
you've got up there from the north and
from the East but we've seen no actual
offensive action into Kiev over the last
three days we have seen
uh residential targets hit by the
Russians there can we read anything into
that yes and this is that other part of
Plan B unfortunately
um as we have been saying the likely
next move if they haven't got the forces
that can actually seize and take these
cities is to surround them bombard them
and put pressure through the population
through terrorizing the population on
zelinski to force him to negotiate and
give Russia something for this military
adventurism and can you lend us your
analysis of what might have happened
over the weekend in yavarev the Russian
missiles falling so close to a NATO
border what does that mean well if our
assessment of Plan B is correct and
these all these areas the Russian forces
are having to reset resupply and re-cock
they're in a race with the very
successful Ukrainian Armed Forces who
are similarly trying to resupply so what
Russia is trying to do here is send a
message out there at yavarev it's saying
to the West don't think about
resupplying the Ukrainian forces yeah
okay thank you very much